now it's funny you've mentioned about
uh you've had a lot of kind words to say
about bitcoin and
um ethereum as important technology that
paved the way for the future
and you somehow did not mention one of
the most profound pieces of technology
which is dogecoin
uh what are your thoughts about this
particular uh
uh revolutionary technology and what are
your thoughts about deutsche coin going
to the moon
to mars and outside of the solar system
i think dogecoin is um is a very
interesting kind of uh
probably closer to a social experiment
than than anything else
isn't everything a social experiment
yeah i i guess that's fair to
to a degree yeah um i think it's
fascinating how that's evolved
um i think the people that made it made
it with certain you know
goals in mind and then it's kind of
taken on a life of its own
i don't fully understand exactly why
it's taking on a life of
of its own at this point um i once again
i don't spend too much time
thinking about you know different tokens
and and how they're evolving
i'm much more focused on on the
launching and um
the technology around trust and all
those kinds of ideas
but you know i think one of the
fascinating things about dogecoin
is the how technology that is
that leverages social dynamics that
technology's ability
to utilize fun and memes
to spread i think it's really
interesting
i i don't think it should be discounted
as a
as if i think i tweeted today something
about like the fundamental force
field of fun that fun
has an effect on the space time so
general relativity
describes how mass and energy
can curve space time and i was just
giving an example that when life is fun
it seems short when life is not fun it
seems very long
so fun has a very similar effect on
space time like in curved space time
in that same sense there there is a
power to the meme
and i think dogecoin illustrates that i
think elon is an example of somebody
that uses dogecoin
i don't know his philosophy but in
particular on this
aspect but he does use it effectively to
excite the world in a
fun way about the possibilities of
future technologies like
cryptocurrency i think the bitcoin world
is very serious right now
and we've spoken to about bitcoin
maximalists
there is very little space for fun and
joking
in the bitcoin world but there's still
a little bit of fun and uh humor left in
the deutsche coin world
in that sense i think it's exceptionally
powerful to inspire to excite
to uh to be able to talk about stuff
without
um without the seriousness
of financial impact that uh now
certain cryptocurrencies have like
bitcoin so
i i keep an eye on the i've previously
mentioned that dogecoin i think
is a fascinating piece of technology
because i do think cryptocurrency is
much bigger than
uh the the technology that they that you
focus on
there is also social element that you
also spoke to
that's uh i think not quite yet
understood
and it's fascinating to watch especially
as it covals
with the different tools on the internet
the social networks
social network mechanisms on the
internet so
i'm a huge supporter of deutsche coin
because i'm a huge supporter of fun
i'm i'm fascinated to see how how it'll
work out
you think i'll go to the moon you think
it'll be the first cryptocurrency to
land on the moon
i i couldn't say i i haven't i haven't
done the analysis as
i've said before i haven't done the
analysis well yeah
no matter what i do hope we uh we'll get
humans back on the moon
and uh hopefully get humans on mars soon
coin bitcoin
or not
you